I've got the function y is equal to X
minus 3 squared times X minus 1 and what
I want to do is think about rotating the
part of this function that sits right
over here between X is equal to 1 and x
equals 3 and x equals 3 and x equals 1
or clearly the zeros of this function
right over here and I want to take this
region I want to take this region and
rotate it around the y axis and if I did
that I get a shape that looks something
like that and I want to figure out the
volume of that shape and what we're
going to do is a new method called the
shell the shell method and the reason
where we use the shell method you might
say hey in the past we've rotated things
around a vertical line before we use the
disk method we wrote everything as a
function of Y etc etc we created all of
these disks we figured out the volume of
each of those disks but the problem here
is this is hard to express as a function
of Y it's hard to express how do you
solve explicitly for Y right over here
so instead we're going to keep things in
terms of X and have a different
geometric visualization for how we can
come up with the volume what we're going
to imagine instead instead of
constructing disks we're going to
construct shells and what do I mean by a
shell so for each exit the interval we
can say we can construct on this kind of
cut of it we can construct a rectangle
and what happens if we were to rotate
this rectangle so this is the rectangle
right over here this is the rectangle
right over here what happens if we
rotate this rectangle around the y axis
along with everything else well it's
going to look something like I'll try my
best attempt to draw it it's going to
look something like something like this
this is challenging my art skills but I
think I can handle it so it's going to
look something something not too
dissimilar to that right over there so
it looks kind of like a hollowed-out
cylinder or I guess that's what we call
it a shell and it's going to have some
depth the depth is going to be DX so the
depth right over here is going to be DX
the depth right over here is going to be
DX and the height right over here is
going to be the value of my function the
height is f of X in this case f
X is X minus 3 squared times X minus 1
how do we figure out the volume of a
cylinder like this well if we can figure
out the circumference of the cylinder if
we can figure out the circumference of
the cylinder and then multiply that
circumference times the height of the
cylinder we'd essentially figure out the
area of the outside surface of our
cylinder and then if we multiply the
cylinder by that infinitesimally small
depth then that will give us the volume
I shouldn't say cylinder of our shell so
let's try to do it what is the
circumference what is the circumference
of a shell the circumference
of one shell going to be well it's going
to be 2 pi times the radius of that
shell which is going to be we need to
express this as a function of X and so
what is that going to be it's going to
be two pi so for a given x what is the
radius well the radius right over here
is just the distance the horizontal
distance between the y-axis and that X
and that's so that's just X so the
circumference in this case it's just
going to be 2 pi times X now what is the
height going to be at any one of those
at any one of those for any one of those
shells the height is going to be f of X
f of X this is right over here and so
what is going to be the surface area of
the outside so let me put this in quotes
outside outside surface area surface
area I'm not well I'm not worried about
the depth right now the DX I'm not
worried about this kind of top part and
the bottom part I'm just worried about
the outside surface area well the
outside surface area is just going to be
the circumference times the height it's
going to be 2 pi x times f of X times f
of X and in this situation in the
situation we're looking at right over
here that's going to be 2 pi X times X
minus 3 squared times X minus 1 now
what's going to be the volume so the
volume of the shell shell shell volume
is just
to be all of this business x times DX so
it's going to be 2 pi x times f of X DX
and so now we're ready to integrate
we're ready to integrate over the
interval so the volume of our entire
shape the volume of our entire shape is
going to be the definite integral we're
going to integrate over all the X's in
the interval from X is equal to 1 to X
is equal to 3 X is equal to 1/2 x equals
3 of this thing and we could take the 2
pi out front so we'll put 2 pi out front
and on the inside we have x times f of X
which in our situation is this business
so it's going to be x times X minus 3
squared times X minus 1 and then of
course we have our we have our DX so
there you have it using the shell method
we have set up our definite integral for
the volume of this strange-looking shape
right over there